developer Turtle Rock has announced the
co-op shooter evolve will be going
free-to-play on PC I'm Lucy and welcome
to your for v1 gamespot news updates the
news was posted on the official evolve
website and follows on from speculation
that the game would be switching to a
free-to-play model after the studio
teased a big announcement Turtle Rock
has announced that they're making evolve
free on PC as a beta from today July
seventh they're currently updating the
game with various tweaks and changes
including reworking the hunter classes
to make the team less reliant on having
experienced trappers and medics making
improvements to the maps and you I
improving load times overall performance
and getting you into the game faster
focusing on improving stability and
fixing bugs completely reworking the
progression system and tutorials and
adding more customization options those
who already purchased evolve will be
granted founder status in the new free
version and all the content you already
own will come with you to the brand new
version additionally players with the
founder status will be granted gifts
rewards and special access if all first
launched in February 2015 4 ps4 xbox one
and pc the gamers ship more than 2.5
million copies and is now described by
take to CEO strauss zelnick as being one
of the company's permanent and long-term
franchises so what do you think of the
move to a free-to-play model will it get
you to play evolve again let me know in
the comments below or come by me on
Twitter I'm at Lisa James games for more
on evolve make sure you keep it gamespot